a given lake has a surface area of 1
million square ft for the past month
about 4 in of rain have been observed at
this location there is an inflow to the
lake which occurs at a rate of 2 cubic
feet per second and an outflow leading
away from the lake which discharges at
1.9 cubic feet per second evaporation at
the location has been measured to be
about 5 in per month infiltration of the
lake bed has been estimated to be 1 inch
per month
assume that the sides of the lake are
impervious is the change in volume of
the lake during this month positive or
negative and by how much answer in cubic
feet so this problem starts out by
giving you a lot of information however
in this case all of it is actually
useful and if you are able to recognize
it it's giving you components of the
hydrologic budget so that's something we
can find in chapter 6 of the reference
manual
and even if you aren't entirely sure if
the words hydrologic budget don't come
back to you you could try to search
something else like evaporation and if
you're lucky it'll lead you to the same
place evaporation is one of those words
that'll do that so let's write out the
equation for surface water system
hydrologic budget to get
started we have the equation of p plus q
n minus Q
out plus Q
subg
minus E Subs - t
Subs - I
equal Delta
S as you can see in the reference manual
P stands for precipitation qn is the
surface water flow into the system Q out
is the surface water flow out of the
system Qs is the groundwater flow
into the stream or lake es s is the
surface evaporation TS is transpiration
I is
infiltration and Delta s is the change
in the water storage of the surface
water system so this problem is asking
us about the change in the volume which
is going to be Delta s and we're going
to find that by plugging in all of the
other parameters that we've been given
for this problem some of them might need
to be solved for a little bit so let's
get started we're going to start by
solving for p p in this case is
precipitation which is noted to be 4 in
over 1 million square ft so we
have 1 million
oops feet squared
times 4
intimes 1T over 12 in
and that will give
us
333,000
cubic feet we're going to try to solve
for everything in cubic feet over a
period of a month since that's the
timetable that the question is asking
for next we're going to solve
for Q in minus Q out and we can solve
this for both both of these terms at
once based on the way the problem gives
us the inflow and the outflow in the
same units so what we can do is
say Q Inus Q out
equals 2 cubic feet per second minus
1.9 cubic feet per
second times 60 seconds in a
minute
time 60
minutes in an
hour
times 24
hours in a day times an average of 30
days in a
month and solving for that we should get
29,200
cubic
feet per
month next we're looking for there is no
Q subg in this problem so we can cross
it out but we have evaporation here and
that's been measured at 5 Ines a month
so we can say well evap
equals 5
in per
month
times foot over 12
in
Time 1
million square
ft and that will give us 416
667 cubic
feet next we have no transpiration given
in this problem but we do have
infiltration and that's been estimated
at 1 in per
month so so what we have here is the
same as above 1 in per
month time 1 ft over 12
intimes 1 million square ft in the lake
and this will give us
333 cubic
feet so now we need to find the delta in
the storage is the lake getting more
water over the course of the month or is
it losing water so which of these
variables would we want to add and which
of these would we want to subtract so
precipitation is going to be an
inflow so let's say plus 3 3 3 3 3 3 and
these are all in the same units
now um Q in minus Q out became positive
so we can leave that as positive since
there's more inflow than out flow and
that's going to be
259 200 evaporation is going to take
water away so 416 667 is a minus and
then infiltration is going to also be a
negative here since that's another
source of water
loss so that's everything we had to
solve for and if we solve for all of
these out what we should get
is
92,000
533 cubic feet in the positive so the
Delta storage has been increasing in
this problem our answer over here is the
second and that should be all it takes
as you can tell this problem just takes
a long time to grind through it's just a
number of calculations and knowing what
the equation is for the hydrologic
budget but it's very straightforward
other than that
so that's
it